si ya aumenta la lista porque a
estrasburgo lille o rodes se suman ahora
París Marsella bogdu Nancy y Hans todas
estas ciudades dicen que no van a ser
publicidad de los partidos de la Copa
del Mundo de Qatar a 2022 es decir no
van a poner una fan son una zona de fans
no van a poner una pantalla gigante para
transmitir estos encuentros por tres
razones la primera de ellas es ecológica
recordemos que es bien polémico este
mundial porque el país va a climatizar
los estadios o sea va a gastar una
cantidad enorme de energía para bajar la
temperatura en un país casi desértico en
los estadios El otro es por un tema de
Derechos Humanos recordemos amnistía
internacional lo venía alertando hace
tiempo ha muerto muchos trabajadores en
la construcción de los ocho estadios que
se van a usar en esta copa del mundo en
la organización dice que ha muerto tres
personas Pero según la organización
Internacional del trabajo son sólo 50 en
el año 2022 y más de las personas
heridas de gravedad y la tercera varios
de estos alcaldes de estas ciudades son
ecologistas o gobiernan en acuerdo con
los ecologistas dicen que no se le puede
pedir a los franceses sobriedad
energética ahorrar energía y en cambio
instalar una gran pantalla que consume
mucha electricidad y algo además que es
temporal que no va a ser obviamente
duradero para las ciudades incluso la
ciudad de Nancy va más lejos y dice que
la FIFA debería considerar ya los temas
ecológicos y de Derechos Humanos al
otorgar estas copas del mundo y no
solamente la FIFA sino todas las
organizaciones y en ese sentido se
refieren a la designación hoy de Arabia
Saudita como la sede de los Juegos
Olímpicos de invierno asiáticos del año
2029 Raúl Algo súper polémico un país
desértico que va a transformar una parte
del territorio en una zona invernal
increíble